we're going to begin with a story it
happens to be very close to my life at
the moment in life of millions of others
americans it's an update to a story
we've been following for years now after
the deaths of more than 100 babies in
unregulated infant sleepers the consumer
product safety commission will now begin
regulating the products it's a big deal
it says the move will effectively
eliminate
potential hazards for infants under five
months old
until now there were no safety standards
for infant
sleep products like inclined and in-bed
sleepers
which the advocacy group consumer
reports has linked to
at least 100 infant deaths the sleepers
will face similar regulations as cradles
and bassinets already do
our consumer investigative reporter anna
werner has been reporting on the dangers
of some of these products for years
anna good morning to you so lay it out
for us what does this new rule mean
well tony you know these products are so
popular federal regulators say
roughly one in three families owns
one or more of these products that were
never previously regulated
the new regulations will cover any
inclined sleep
product along with in-bed sleepers and
baby boxes
for infants up to five months old that
covers any product referencing
sleep snooze dream or nap and anything
that depicts sleeping or can be
described as a bed
now millions of these incline products
have been voluntarily recalled
including the fisher-price rock and play
sleeper
nearly 5 million of those were recalled
and the cpsc
linked it to more than 30 deaths in 2019
we spoke to two couples whose infants
died
in a rock and play he was our little
baby our little quota buddy
you're a little cuddle buddy yeah she
was perfect
aria was perfect i don't go a day
without
thinking about her i would like to raise
awareness
there's people out here that are still
using the rock and play sleeper that
our children died in
and guess what despite recalls we went
online this week
and in 10 minutes found more than 50
recalled inclined sleepers
for sale on facebook marketplace
secondhand sleepers now
a facebook spokesperson told us that
those postings violated company policies
prohibiting the sale of recalled goods
and they have been removed a
spokesperson for fisher-price said
product safety is their highest priority
that they voluntarily recalled the rock
and play sleeper more than two years ago
they said they vigilantly monitor
secondary marketplaces
and work hard to remove listings that
they have identified
experts say if you own one of these
products do not use them
stop using them and you should not sale
or sell i'm sorry or donate them to
anybody else
you can reach out to the company for a
refund or a voucher tony yeah and we had
one we actually went back and got that
refund my heart absolutely breaks
for those families something you've
talked about before is
why these products are so potentially
dangerous can you remind us
yeah so one thing people don't realize
you put a baby into an
inclined product where they're slightly
on an angle when they fall asleep their
head can fall forward like this now you
and i we pick our head back up
but these babies they don't have the
muscles to pick their head back
back up so they basically choke off
their airway or
they may turn slightly this way and
because the side of the product is soft
they wind up with their face in the soft
product and they have suffocated
yeah it's such a hard situation because
parents are so desperate for sleep of
any kind and these inclines
can help with digestion and all the rest
but it's important now that the consumer
product safety commission
is going to set some standards so there
is some reassurance that things are safe
anna thank you very much and i do want
to remind viewers that the american
academy of pediatrics says that infants
should sleep on their backs only and
they should also sleep on a firm surface
in a crib or bassinet that is approved
with a fitted sheet
and nothing else around them no blankets
no toys no bumpers this does not have to
be expensive in fact you can get a box
literally a cardboard box
a baby box put your child in that it's
the safest thing
we did it it works yeah it does work
yeah i'm so glad that the parents are
talking and that anna did the story
because those sleep and plays look like
such a cool thing for the baby
yeah for the parents it looks very
soothing and very often the kids love it
and it's
all you want as a parent and you feel
that you're being supported by
regulation
there wasn't any in the past now there
is going to be that's a good thing
very important story